hi I'm Greg I'm John I wanted to force
the forces with me on the road once not
as trailers this was requested from
people oh good I don't know man
this was first requested from d FK 220
the FK down [ __ ] kingpin he is the
kingpin who was always around me but
yeah yeah warning the following videos
is in its quarters for road one a stone
war story
wears out rose from root I was seriously
going to learn how to sell road so many
people view Linda a new hope you
remember Darth Vader
now prepare to member the handful of
members between the rise of Darth Vader
and the start of the new whole we call
it oh goodness rehash everything from
Star Wars are they I thought a bad
evening honey Rouge one a story get
ready for Disney's first Star Wars
anthology movie because there's no way
in hell they'd call it Star Wars prequel
number four it would has to be the most
money anyone's ever spent to fill in
apply old dock planes I've laid my trap
[Music]
that answers your most pressing
questions how exactly did the rebels get
the plans to the Death Star did they
grab a data tape with a giant claw
machine then use a big antenna to be the
data tape to a ship and then did that
ship transfer the digger to another
smaller team and then the princess
Leia's coming back laundry what do I
tell you doing hard drive you know
whoever said this one is as good as
empire must be really into file formats
meet an all-new gang of rebels you put
this shouldn't get too attached
hahaha like jyn erso a rebellious rebel
who rebelled so hard she does whatever
her dad tells her she must eat whatever
her surrogate dad tells her don't you -
you must good and whatever her new
co-worker tells her yeah no but
sometimes she's pretty grumpy about it
hmm
rebelling alongside Gaea his k2s oh boy
with more personality than any of the
human characters I'll command for you
captain
Quebec height cassia a rebel whose most
heroic moment comes when he doesn't
murder someone for once I had every
chance to the tree leg I saw Guerrera an
extremist cast out of the Alliance by
extensively shoes oh good the blond guy
is technically not a Jedi but I mean
come on
pretty this guy gutting the cute face I
had more but that's pretty much all
there is to this guy cow beak with a
bite of the Empire as various old dudes
squabble over who gets credit for the
death star we send more to you dawn
while down on the battlefield
stormtroopers are rolling out in two
brand new flavors but with the same old
incompetence were used to whether
they're missing easy shots
[Music]
casually getting taken out setting up
their weaknesses six that the Ewoks
would take advantage of
[Music]
why doesn't even bother with the armor
at all enjoy one of the most beautiful
Star Wars films today that feels like
the world's biggest budget fan filled
full of Easter retro me will have
diehard fans a goner
red leader summit on the guidance of the
will I get that reference say it's
prequel guy Nobu milk okay I like him
you just won so that's where those
Cantina guys were they were walking
around t-15 yeah I'm going to look at it
later
whoa what it's awesome way to put target
in the book never mind
and this feels wrong somehow but doesn't
have service say it's harder and faster
that dark freaking fader has a much
older sounding James Earl Jones tries to
give us a new iconic see you gentlemen
children your master issues let George
Lucas right-aligned now but just when
you think he's been wasted
extend your lightsabers for the most
badass Star Wars moment down the hallway
see which makes majors next slide in the
timeline even sillier than it already
was
[Music]
the falling shells you saw in the
trailers that weren't in the movie kid
vs. a TIE fighter through working
together absolute high state war-torn
scary this iconic shot of gin undercover
unused vader solder errors other haircut
the shot they think the whole marketing
campaign on all these other cool shots
and this slide this is a rebellion isn't
it
IRA bad ok cutting that would make sense
Suicide Squad force works creepy
Internet has enough Star Wars shows
think again new production all new show
with professional gun range any nipples
hood to explore the outer rim of the
Star Wars universe watch this week as
she tackles what Star Wars creatures
would you meet then puts her credits
where her mouth is in the ultimate
galactic taste test wait here for me
roll it screen junkies Millennium Falcon
Weekly's and it's free why rish are they
on screen John these news I know him
he's a friend from work
I want that moolah McNugget sauce more
tea
I've talked my pants I can't wait for
Disney to announce the Michael Bay slash
M night Shyamalan co-directed Jar Jar a
Star Wars story we all flowed down here
this is how we do it it's Friday night
yay yay yay
they always raised some good points
those screen junkies giant crew at
screen junkies has done it again I
wonder which specific person wrote this
one that was really fun that was really
funny I did not realize just how many
shots were in the trailers that were
not in the actual movie I was able to
maybe have a couple yeah you did very
distinct ones like the famous one word
is a lesser coming you see dinner or so
undercover that the TIE fighter and I
Ravel are the ones that always said to
me yeah that was I was pretty crazy man
I really I just movie went through so
many reshoot no even hadn't even noticed
that four and a different haircut at
some of the shots on the trailers when
they pointed that out I was like oh well
he doesn't have like a big like the
unkempt hairdo like all the time you
know it's weird I find a lot of people
who don't like this movie and it kind of
upsets me because this is one of my
favorite Star Wars yeah I thought this
was one of the best ones I really
enjoyed it ii think i'm going to talk to
the internet yeah
i would play an iron new hope and in
this one okay
i would just give my real choice I would
say Empire this one a new hope force
awakens okay yeah well you know you is
really my second favorite okay
I'm surprised to hear that because most
people I've come across seem to be
really positive about it but I don't it
doesn't come up in my daily life as much
I really like this and I'm not a huge
you know Star Wars phonetic so this is
either one of my favorite Star Wars
movies - well they make jokes about how
it's just like a fan film that sounded
very unnecessary and while it
technically isn't like unnecessary is
building episode eight also not
necessary and you're like at seven
whatever you have there's a lot of all
projects are worried about us you don't
have to do it is hold that organ and now
we're just looking for other story you
know but I felt that they still gave us
some really cool characters k2s I did
have the most like personality out of
them all but I thought they were all
very distinct I like Kathy Anna I like
the whole crew in this movie like even
if you know even if you don't
necessarily get to love these characters
like yet doing some of the other Star
Wars characters I thought they they
handle the ensemble well and they
everybody brought a lot to their room
especially for characters that a very
specific crew that would only took place
in this one
movie you're not seeing these guys than
anything else they're only in his one
film I thought they all did it like an
amazing job and I felt yeah while
there's easy ones the favor you know
everyone's gonna k2so4 Donnie Yen Donnie
and Cheer it children sure oh sure oh
sure everybody loves a good sheriff yeah
and the other asian guy bezel but now he
was I know my Star Wars very well
dressed my I remember everything I hear
in all these movies I like this movie a
lot and the thing was like this was to
me the most interesting thing that come
out of stores in LA because I liked the
force awakens even but this is like oh
we're telling a different tone of movie
which felt to me a little more worth
wild and some of the other stuff we've
done with Star Wars over time so I guess
yeah well I understand the fan fiction
or human I'm like well hey at least it
invigorated me again I thought it was a
great piece of fan fiction if anything
yeah yeah and that's what we're doing
now like basically all it is is fan
fiction like that's what it's gonna be
now cuz now you've got all these people
who grew up on Star Wars and who loved
Star Wars and someone's gonna get lucky
enough to do their own fan fiction
that's happened to be gara that was ya
know and whoever else was on that script
I did like how they pointed out how
characters are like taking out
stormtroopers lipsticks yeah yeah
stormtroopers is never going to agree
are the worst as their jobs why do
people collect stormtrooper toys they
are terrible for the surgery because
they look cool again they look good and
I think you can feel morally alright
about the idea that they're probably not
going to kill anybody too important and
they're not badass stormtroopers even
phasma even phasma's not a bad answer
generally all are doing cool silver
outfit we're going to see god she's
going to show up be grumpy and leaving
in man well guys thank you for telling
us this was out honest trailers they're
awesome and you signor has approved us
of doing these reactions so before you
harp on our asses it is just a signal
certified signor certified I like signor
Joestar he's my favorite my fate the
funniest one with screen junkies yeah I
think Jodi's are think simons
biggest fan it's possible every time I
see him I'm like you're like the phony
who's good at strategic yeah you say you
know you let him know I got a tournament
of nerds and lo futures or so foot hey
Joe star was a revelation on tournament
of nerds his Green Power Ranger was
magic I just want to live inside Joe's
beard we went to what was the place
called the complex peaky blinders yeah I
believe it was called the turkey burger
the burger the Joe started stand up
we've seen Joe star on movie fights and
this and his honest trailers who've seen
him in like do commentary we've seen a
determiners rated M strong character
then we saw you stand up this guy is
funny has [ __ ] all around yeah we've
seen him dude like one of every band of
comedy is funny as [ __ ] go follow
Joseph's dog subscribe to the real
rejects
1-800 reasons to Jerry is my phone
number you can get me on the Twitter
Instagram and reasons to Jerry head on
over to bloom house comm Blum house calm
on the social media management over
there but also there's just a bunch of
cool stuff there you like genre films
facebook.com slash the real rejects is
where you can find all kinds of things
that are interesting to us and also you
know new videos even though Facebook
just hates youtube links yeah everyone's
algorithm just no one wants us to
succeed hey guys have a good night I
love you goodbye